we have been waiting for apple to bring  back touch id for years now but i  believe that this will never happen and  we will never have under display touch  id on any iphone and i believe there are  three reasons why it won't because this  keeps getting delayed and delayed the  leaks and the rumors and of course it is  fun but after you go from year to year  and it keeps getting pushed back it is  just annoying face id itself is getting  better the technology that allows face  id to work is getting smaller they're  working on it working underneath the  display as well and once they reach that  do they need to have an underneath the  display face id and touch id at the same  time i don't think so they release the  ability to finally use face id with a  mask now this part of it just blows my  mind and this is the clear reason that i  think they're ditching touch id i do  think that they still will have touch id  just not under the display technology